hi this is presh talwalkar
star basketball players always seem to
get in a rhythm
they make one shot and then they make
another and soon it seems like they
can't miss
surely this is evidence of the hot hand
you get too confident in this
observation
remember that intuition is often a poor
guide for probability
for example imagine a basketball player
who has a 50 accuracy rate so that each
shot is like a coin flip
if you ask people to predict the result
of 10 shots
they will have about 5 shots being made
and they'll alternate between hits and
misses
in reality many times the player will
have several hits in a row and several
misses in a row
and this has nothing to do with the
player having the hot hand or being on a
cold streak
this is simply the result of random
probability
so what's the answer is the hot hand
actually true
in 1985 an academic study found the hot
hand was a fallacy
they said the hot hand was a
misperception of random sequences
in other words
the sequences of players making shots in
a row or missing shots in row were just
the result of random sequences
a player who had made several shots in a
row was not more likely to make the next
shot than he was just to make a regular
shot in a row
this study became quite famous and for
30 years we thought the hot hand was a
fallacy
a new working paper is saying there was
actually a subtle statistical mistake in
this paper
they're saying the hot hand does exist
and there's a truth to it
this is causing a little bit of
controversy where people are trying to
say why the original paper was wrong
and whether the hot hand really exists
so let's go a little bit into the
probability and see why this new working
paper actually seems to have uncovered a
statistical mistake in the original
paper
i'm going to have to talk about a little
bit of statistics
and i'm going to talk about population
formulas versus sample estimator
formulas
so imagine you want to measure the
average weight of all adults
and we have a population size of n n is
very big if you wanted to find the
average weight you would take the
average of each person you would add up
each person's weight and you would
divide it by the population size
the population formula for the average
weight the average mean is mu is equal
to one over n times the sum of each
person's weight
now it's not often practical
to take the average weight of millions
of people so what we do in practice is
we take a random sample and this will be
for a sample of size n
in order to get an estimator of the
average weight we would actually just
take the sample of the average
in the average so
our
estimator our sample formula
is the is x bar is equal to one over n
times the sum of the individuals so you
can see these two formulas are actually
pretty similar the population formula
where we know each observation and the
sample formulas are pretty much the same
except we're substituting the different
sizes in our formulas
but now let me ask you another question
let's say you wanted to calculate the
variance of the weight in adults
in a population of size n the formula is
to look at the square difference from
the mean
and then divide that by the population
size n
that'll give you the variance of the
population
so if you wanted to do the same thing in
a random sample you might think you
could just substitute little n wherever
you see big n and instead of knowing the
population mu parameter mean we would
substitute the sample mean so you would
think this sample estimate
of the variance would be a true and
valid formula for calculating for
estimating the variance in the
population
however
this is a biased estimator
and one of the main problems is
we don't know what the true mean in the
population is we're relying on the fact
that we're using a sample average in
order to calculate the variance so this
introduces a little bit of bias and in
order to get an unbiased formula we
actually have to divide by n minus 1
which will make our variance in the
sample a little bigger
you actually may have encountered this
formula if you use a spreadsheet
you'll see that it actually many times
they'll calculate the sample variance
and they'll divide by n minus one so
this is also true for the sample
standard deviation
the lesson here is that the population
formula will not always apply when
you're looking at a smaller sample
sometimes the sample formulas need to be
adjusted to get an accurate estimator of
the population
so now let's return to basketball
imagine a player has a 50 accuracy rate
so that each shot is like flipping a
coin
in four shots how often do you expect to
observe a shot being made a shot hit
after already seeing a hit
so there are 16 different ways
that a player can uh shoot
with a 50 accuracy rate and these will
all be equally likely
now in the very first observation where
we have three misses and then a hit
there actually is no shot after
the hit so we want to know how often do
you observe a shot being made after a
shot already being made in this first
observation
the hit is already in the final shot so
this observation doesn't matter
in the next observation of all misses
there are no hits at all
so these two things will just rule out
so now we have 14 different trials and
we're going to calculate how often do we
observe a shot being made after a shot
already being made
well in the first trial where we have
all hits there's a 100 chance that we're
going to observe a hit after a hit
in the second
observation the first shot was a hit and
the second shot is also a hit
the second shot is a hit and the third
shot is also a hit however the third
shot is a hit and afterwards we have a
miss
so in two out of the three or 66 and
two-thirds percent chance in this trial
we observe a hit after a hit
so i can compute the same type of
probability in each
of the different trials
so what we're doing is we're looking at
the empirical chance that we're going to
observe a shot being made after a shot
already being made
now these 14 trials
are equally likely and when you average
this out
we find a sample estimate of only about
40
that we observe a hit being made a shot
being made after a shot is already made
and we know this is wrong because we
know the true probability is 50
each shot is a coin flip so after you
make a shot it's going to be a 50 chance
so there's actually a bias in the sample
estimate because a lot of times when you
just make one shot there's a miss right
after it so that puts a downward bias on
our estimate
so in order to get
an accurate test of
whether we observe a hit after a shot
already being made we need to adjust the
sample formula to get an unbiased
estimate of the true probability
so that brings us back to our two papers
the claim is that the original paper
actually had a mistake in its sampling
it actually was more likely to pick
sequences where you would have a miss
after a hit
the new paper is saying that when you
correct for this error
the hot hand actually does exist and
some players
would actually have a 10 percentage
point increase in a shot being made as a
after a sequence submit of shots being
made as opposed to a sequence of shots
being missed so they're saying the hot
hand actually does exist when you
correct for this sample bias
so what's the lesson in all this i know
so basketball analytics is a kind of
controversial topic and people don't
want to say that statistics can be
useful
but i'm still going to say we need
analytics because intuition about
probability can be very wrong
but this whole study shows us that we
need to be careful there are very subtle
things that can influence the way we
collect data and the way we analyze data
but it's pretty neat that they did find
the hot hand is probably true and this
paper still needs to undergo peer review
and be published
but from what i can tell and from the
mathematics i presented to you it seems
like the hot hand does exist
so whenever you hear a commentator
saying yeah you need to give it to him
he has the hot hand
for once it seems that analytics is
supporting the intuition that sports
fans had observed for a long time
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon
you can catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books i've
provided links in the video description